il aime buzzati michel ces objets
chantal hébert bonsoir bonsoir on va
parler monsieur o'toole mais d'abord je
veux vous entendre sur les annonces qui
ont été faites hier sur les crêtes en
ontario qu'on a entendu aujourd'hui du
maire de toronto qui dit on devrait
peut-être faire comme au québec là les
cas augmentent dangereusement
je veux entendre monsieur legault ce
matin qui plaidait qu'il avait pris les
bonnes décisions
la veille il ya des mesures qui ont
annoncé hier qu'ils sont pour trois
semaines certaines sont pour deux
semaines
quand on regarde le nombre de décès
quand on compare la situation dans les
dernières semaines notre situation était
meilleure que celle de l'allemagne
par contre c'est serré du côté des
hôpitaux donc il ya beaucoup de facteurs
qui font qu'on a choisi des mesures
qu'ont annoncé hier
alors j'attends je commence avec vous
une cette annonce
ok cette annonce au québec hier je le
répète pour les gens au début je le
disais il ya beaucoup de gens mélanger
mais finalement on peut recevoir une
personne seule qui pourra aller dans une
bulle mais pas dans plusieurs bulles
pour le reste c'est à peu près le
confinement qu'on a connu tout ce qui
est une zone essentielle je vous demande
tout comme experte en sentez vous n'êtes
pas experte mais en terme de
communication politique et du moment
choisi est ce que c'était approprié la
maman choisi oui le bon moment choisi
parce que monsieur legault n'est pas le
terrain il n'y a personne qui ont été
étonnés d'entendre ce qu'ils ont entendu
et j'imagine que si le gouvernement
devant des chiffres catastrophiques
parce que grippe saisonnière se
réveiller 2 janvier avec une situation
qui est encore pire qu'aujourd'hui on
préparera le terrain à prolonger
certaines des mesures pas tout
nécessairement est il là je pense aux
enfants du primaire et aux vautours en
classe mais changerait probablement à
prolonger ces fermetures d'heure parce
que c'est une chose qu'on a appris cet
automne c'est que c'est pas parce qu'on
annonce 28 jours de fermeture de quelque
chose que ça devient koi 66 oui on peut
pas fermer la porte à son effectif à
michel c je pense que c'est un petit peu
compliqué oui mais c'est pas si
compliqué que ça que les règles georges
au soccer
c'est compliqué de les créer mais quand
on voit un souci alors ça tombe sous le
sens à peu près l'aurez compris la
personne toute seule qu'on peut éviter
tout ça c'est des mesures qui touchent
ce sens et si des mesures aussi qui sont
dictées par les chiffres
les chiffres sont têtus on peut pas les
enlever c'est pas beau actuellement
c'est pour vous d'une part au canada et
ils font faire quelque chose d'assez
chose qu'on pourra dire à la fin de
l'exercice
or on avait des gens à faire plus pour
moi il y arrivera peut-être pour leur
confiant comme un peu plus loin
ouais il a nagé
le maire de toronto ça m'a frappé
aujourd'hui que dit regardez au québec
la faux arrêtons de penser que nous on
est plus protégé il faudrait qu'on soit
un peu plus sévère également qu'est ce
que vous en pensez mais écoutez je pense
que chaque chaque juridiction prend ses
propres décisions selon sa situation
épidémiologique moi j'ajouterai à ce que
tous mes collègues m'ont dit je suis
assez d'accord mais je ne comprends pas
pourquoi monsieur legault autant attendu
pour annoncer la question des écoles
primaires j'avais une certaine sympathie
pour les enseignants qu'on entendait
plutôt à l'émission qui disaient oui
mais vous savez on apprend maintenant
que finalement il n'y aura pas de cours
la première semaine de janvier qu'on
devrait leur faire faire des exercices
quand est-ce qu'on était supposé
préparer ces exercices ça a été annoncé
hier soir et pour plusieurs enfants
aujourd'hui était la dernière journée en
présentiel pour 30 ce mot là je ne
comprends pas trop pourquoi on a tant
attendu sur cette question je veux quand
même lever mon chapeau sur cette idée
que l'on emprunté notamment à la france
de deux empêcher les sous les grandes
surfaces le de vendre certains produits
qui ne sont pas essentiels pour ne pas
faire concurrence aux petits commerçants
c'est quelque chose qui était attendu
c'est un petit peu compliqué à gérer
mais pas tant que ça et je pense qu'il
ya bien des commerçants qui sont
d'accord à l'ex en question d'équité
élémentaire les commerçants qu'on oblige
de fermer les vaccins ça va nous amener
à monsieur aux tournées les vaccins on
en a parlé
déjà il ya quoi le temps passe vite la
semaine dernière et comme je te dois
annoncer finalement que ça allait se
faire plus vite qu'on avait dit là ça
s'installe assez ronde mal évidemment
les quantités le new york times nous
disait hier que père capital canada est
numéro un sur la planète on a tellement
acheter compris vacciner six fois la
population canadienne et les un tour de
table je commence avec vous pour
l'instant ça va plutôt bien
oui et en passant on le savait déjà à
monsieur trudeau le tlm en dix chapitres
aurait fait celui qui en avait le plus
et ça dépendra avec le temps on sait pas
quelle est la durée limitée octroyé par
ce vaccin
peut-être que par le temps que tous ses
autres vaccins soit approuvé on aura
besoin de dose de rappel est donc
peut-être pour l'europe besoin de tout
ça mais ça va effectivement rondement
faudra quand même voir quand le rythme
des arrivages vont augmenter parce qu'il
augmentera éventuellement est ce qu'on
sera capable de suivre la cadence
quand même moi je pense que j'écoutais
monsieur au tout à l'heure vous parlez
je pense qu'il doit être un peu mal à
l'aise parce que dans les dernières
semaines il avait mis beaucoup de ses
oeufs dans ce panier lors de la
vaccination
il tapait toujours sur ce clou en ce
sens au gouvernement il avait été trop
là et là surprise on dame le pion aux
états unis les choses vont bien il se
retrouve un petit peu sans ligne
d'attaqué ça paraissait d'ailleurs dans
son entrevue il a patiné beaucoup sur
cette question je pense que pas tout
compris chaque mois les trouver michel
j'espère que monsieur otto il se rend
compte que quand cet acquis et sur les
vaccins n'étaient pas sur la boîte sur
la bonne voie
oui tiens je trudeau là-dessus mais je
n'étais pas obligé de mettre les deux
pieds dedans et puis la vaccination va
bien parce que elle et bien planifiée
jusqu'à maintenant et que pas eu de
problèmes logistiques et là je sais que
c'est le dernier maillon de la chaîne
qui compte alors tu peux avant tout fait
parfaitement avant psy le concierge pas
en bonne clip qu'on peut pas ouvrir le
centre de vaccination ça marchera pas
journée leur là c'est un million de
petits détails mais les gens qui
semblent enchaîné qui sont en charge de
ça semble ou bien maîtrisé la situation
1 et et qui se dégageant du coran est le
rapport avec les provinces qui n'est pas
toujours évident il a l'air de très bien
se faire alors au canada est difficile
de demander des lieux habituellement je
vais pas dire que ça vous changera pour
les gens de santé canada aussi qu'ils
l'ont approuvé
des gens aussi de l'ombre on parle de
tous par coeur les policiers mais
j'entendais canada les files au canada
et j'en fais entre bref chantage par ces
mots de choses d'abord simple canada
précisé aujourd'hui ce que j'ai trouvé
assez audacieux que selon eux les selon
l'ap a reçu tous les canadiens qui
veulent surfer avec ce niveau là d'ici
la fin septembre
la plaie bouillot deux semaines monsieur
trudeau s'avancer à une majorité 50% + 1
ou 2 chez les libéraux de majorité c'est
peut-être soissons dans un autre débat
au sein du siège à l'achat c'est ce et
c'est effectivement intéressant de voir
comment ça se passe mais la deuxième
chose c'est aussi un moment où tout ce
qu'ils disent est donc dommage que les
promesses soient responsables de santé
paul fédéral devrait être un peu
confondu parce que la raison pour
laquelle ça va bien c'est parce que des
infrastructures relativement solide dans
chaque province pour faire le relais
entre le fédéral et l'administration du
vaccin et ce serait merveilleux si il
fallait que tous les fonctionnaires de
tower s'occupe de vacciner tout le monde
de revenir à drummondville sur les
transferts en santé je vous avais
demandé la dernière fois qui a le plus
gros bout du bâton
on a vu à la conférence de presse la
semaine dernière que monsieur legault
était très déçu mais ça n'a pas fait le
feu d'artifice que ça déjà fait à une
certaine époque cas les provinces
étaient très fâchés
tu te retrouves d'écouté on est en
pleine pandémie on va attendre avant de
fixer des montagnes adorent plus
d'argent éventuellement comment vous
voyez cette négociation en cours des
prochaines semaines
hélène moi je pense qu'il ira bien
franchement nulle part vous dit le plus
gros bout du bâton moi je vous dirai qui
a le plus gros bout du corps dont le
cordon de la bourse
et c'est ottawa qui l'avons en bout de
piste c'est lui qui décide si on donne
de l'argent ou pas et il est assez clair
que d'ici le prochain de budget pardon
voire même la prochaine élection
ottawa pas vraiment goût de se mettre le
doigt dans cet engrenage monsieur
trudeau le dis tout le temps aux 20 ans
de la fin la part du groupe moi ce que
j'en comprends c'est qu'ils me
voir une fois que ça sera pas assez
quels sont les besoins les plus urgents
dans les systèmes de santé est proposée
aux provinces d'investir de manière
ciblée dans ces secteurs là évidemment
est ce que monsieur autour ne peut faire
du millage passez moi l'expression avec
sa ligne quand il dit chantal moi je
n'imposerai pas de conditions province
je suis votre homme à ottawa ayez
confiance en moi pis tant mieux si vous
avez des amis lire la prochaine fois
deux problèmes le premier c'est que
quand jusqu'à une photo et un hibou quoi
et qui a maintenu le rythme
d'augmentation des transferts s'est
unilatéralement par stephen harper il ya
respecter aussi les arrangements
asymétrique du québec est la province
qui insiste le plus sur cette absence de
conditions alors dans la mesure où
monsieur trudeau continue sur cette
lancée là et enlève le joueur qui parle
le plus fort et dans les faits les gens
à québec vont vous reconnaître le clos
de monsieur legault porte-parole des
provinces un peu en porte à faux par
rapport à l'actuelle déclic la grosse
bataille du québec c'est de maintenir la
symétrie qui dit le québec rendez compte
que ses électeurs et pas au gouvernement
du canada en matière de scientifiques
la deuxième chose évidemment dans le cas
de monsieur autour se passer du parti
conservateur au pouvoir stephen harper
qui une fois que les arrangement négocié
par paul martin explique décidé
unilatéralement et envoie un courriel au
premier ce produit ça va être trois pour
cent à partir de maintenant
merci bon ouais alors en firent
négociations oui alors monsieur jeu j'ai
remarqué dans votre entrevue s'est pas
engagé d'aucune façon à rejoindre la
barre fixée très haut et inatteignable
selon moi par les provinces
alors dans le moment il dit la même
chose que justin trudeau il serait prêt
à en donner plus edit sans condition
c'est sans doute vrai c'est pas clair
encore quelles seraient les conditions
fédéral
quant à michelle bachelet panneautique
monsieur autour de venir une somme
d'argent
allant jusqu'à tard on voit la somme
d'argent en fait on sait pas si est un
grand allié de monsieur legault du
québec et des provinces ne sais pas
alors ça c'est la première des choses la
deuxième c'est qu'il ya quand même un
bout de bon sens dans ce que monsieur
trudeau disait on est en pleine pandémie
c'est peut-être pas le temps de négocier
ces affaires-là l'édifice vient de
sauter adoption par tous en train de
retomber partout attendons que ça
retombe et l'on soit une négociation est
troisième à partir du moment où j'ai
trudeau a ouvert la porte en disant je
je vous le dis tout de suite
j'accepte le fait qu'il va falloir
augmenter ma contribution sa désamorce
un peu moins l'urgence pour les
provinces mais le problème de monsieur
legault entre autres c'est que lui a
besoin de saint jean l'un pour pour pour
boucler son budget dans les prochaines
années si vous regardez prévisible
épreuve il avait ce qu'en termes il
avait ce côté même si lui c'est comme
presse ah bon sur les autres sujets mais
je suis au tour comment ils se situent
comment ils naviguent on en avait parlé
rapidement l'autre fois sur le français
sur l'aide à mourir le finalement ils
ont arrêté leur obstruction sur la
pétition de monsieur cela a pris trois
quatre jours comment vous évaluez son
habilité politique actuellement hélène
mais moi je note quand même qu'il est
viable donnons lui la chance a fait pas
tellement longtemps qu'il est l'homme et
je note qu'il a quand même un peu de
difficulté à mettre son parti au pas
vous l'avez mentionné sur la caisse il
est pro choix mais il laisse des pro-vie
embourbé le débat sur l'aide à mourir
il est pour la science mais il est cette
fameuse pétition le dos dont vous
parliez anti vaccins il ya quand même on
sent qu'il est déchirée entre ses
convictions personnelles qui sont
vraiment progressiste conservatrice et
une certaine base dans son parti je te
carton rouge
oui oui il est écartelé met peu à peu en
train de combler l'écart si vous voulez
moi j'ai trouvé intéressant vendredi
dernier à faire un discours important où
il a parlé des syndicaux les critiques
et l'élite financière qui veut juste
avoir des immigrants pour avoir du type
je sens que monsieur otto le veut faire
de son parti le parti de la classe
ouvrière
il faut comprendre que dans l'ouest
pays entre le parti conservateur et le
npd si souvent un vase communiquant les
électeurs passe de l'un à l'autre et
après des électeurs qui ne se retrouvent
plus dans le npd très de gauche
obsédé par les questions identitaires et
je pense qu'il tentera par ce discours
de récupérer cet électorat
chantal savait pas qu'il ya des
élections parce qu'il y avait une
pandémie mais je me suis demandé est-ce
que c'est le même chef que mené la
charge sur un vote de confiance au
moment du discours du trône alors que la
deuxième vague commencer premier
problème
deuxième problème vous l'avez interview
et je commence à me préoccuper ce qui
dit en privé par rapport à un public
puisque monsieur autour s'est fait
prendre à avoir déclaré au début
novembre des étudiants de ryerson à
toronto que les écoles résidentielles
pour les autochtones finalement ça
partait d'un bon sentiment et c'était
pour les aider à s'éduquer
aujourd'hui le sujet le plus actif dans
les médias sociaux au canada
ça s'appelle démissionner o'toole ayant
été obligé de rallye complètement ses
paroles question si c'est pas volé leur
était pas sorti en public
est ce qu'ils se seraient ravaler
aujourd'hui est de plus en plus point
d'interrogation pour moi c'est qu'il
oeuvrait et renault tout point
d'interrogation shell 30 secondes il a
besoin dit il a besoin d'armes et
certaines choses
énormément de choses et quand on est au
québec par exemple à faire de l'aide
médicale à mourir là pour passer
ailleurs c'est autre chose des
pensionnats autochtones ça va être
pareil un nouveau chef est d'habitude
une espèce de lune de miel
or un temps où les gens nous regardent
de façon sympathique il est en train de
perdre sa très rapidement je suis auto
aussi fait pas attention
merci beaucoup à vous trois bonne soirée
on se retrouve très bientôt revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i see her dit